To properly classify these 2D objects, we
need to look at the blob properties. Now there
are many blob properties that exist, for example
the area, the centroid or the eccentricity.
I've put together some examples in MATLAB
of some of these properties, so let's take
a look at that now.
So in MATLAB here I have four different variables.
The first is my robotic vision worksheet image
and the other three are the binary outputs
from my 'getColor' from my different colour
channels. So the red binary output, the green
binary output and the blue one as well. So
when you're writing your own getShape function,
you're going to have to rely on using the
iblobs function of the toolbox.
So in this video I'm going to show you how
the iblobs works and the different properties
of the blobs that can be returned.
So let's say we want to extract the red blobs.
So we'll make a new variable called red blobs,
and the actual function to extract blobs out
of an image is iblobs, so that's a toolbox
function and how iblobs works is that the
primary input in the binary image that you
want to extract the blobs from. So for us
it's just going to be our 2D.
Now there are many other inputs you can put
for iblobs, and I strongly encourage you to
research about what they are because they
can be used to improve the output of your
own getShape function.
So if we run that, that will extract the red
blobs for us and you can see that it is returned
this list of blobs here. And then we can visualize
this by using idisp, in r2d and then I can
go back to my red blobs and then call plot_box
and then that has highlighted all the red
blobs in this image. And you can see that
it's a binary image, there are the black pixels
and there are white pixels only. And all of
the white shapes in this particular image
have been highlighted with a blue square.
But you might be thinking, "Hold on, there
are six red 2D objects in this image, but
there are seven red blobs that have been returned.
Where's the seventh blob?"
Well if you go back into the image and pay
close attention, you can see that the border
of this image has been highlighted as a blob
as well. And that particular blob has an extremely
large area. You can see its blob number seven
here. So this is how you’re going to have
to classify each of the 2D objects, in particular
shape and size. You're going to have to look
at the blob properties that are returned and
then classify it in terms of these properties.
So you can look at the blob area, it's centroid,
the eccentricity, the perimeter, all those
particular properties combined together can
then enable you to build a hierarchical tree,
such that you can identify something as being a square, circle or a triangle, and what particular size it is.
Last think got note is that anything in image
processing will be affected by the image quality
and noise. So you can't be 100 percent sure
if something is definitely going to be a square.
That's why we're trying to build a classifier
as a tree, such that if something is not a
square and it's not a triangle, then it's
most likely to be a circle.